it's a topic that won't seem to die so
let me make something very clear if you
buy the Hogwarts Legacy game you are
contributing to transphobia even if you
consider yourself an ally even if you
yourself are trans you are contributing
to transphobia and that is not an
opinion it's a fact JK Rowling both
through the word she says and direct
Financial contributions is signal
boosting and enabling multiple groups
and individuals who are actively pushing
for the stripping away and restricting
of Rights of trans people especially in
the UK right now and it's working if you
pay for that game you're contributing to
that rolling has made it very clear she
believes every penny of the residual
checks that she gets to be proof that
people support her and are fine with
what she's doing and no matter what
other rationalizations you have oh I'm
supporting the devs I just really love
this universe that's fine but you are
also contributing to transphobia
although note I said if you buy it
not if you play it there's a debate to
be had about big streamers whether they
should be boosting it but for your
average person if you find a way to get
it without paying for it well